welcome to the grammar of words this is
one of a number of linguistics lessons
on the site and it will introduce you to
how languages build words will cover two
basic topics in this lesson the first is
going to be the components of words and
the second will be a way to classify
types of languages based on how they do
build words two concepts to get you
started the first is the morpheme this
is our basic building block in the
grammar of words a morpheme is the
smallest meaningful unit you can break a
word down into each word has at least
one morpheme so for instance the word
dog is both a word and a morpheme it's
the single morpheme dog if you just
break it down to the duh sound or the
Gus sound you're no longer working with
morphemes the word dogs in the plural
more than one dog has two morphemes it
has the morpheme dog and it has a sound
or sound that tells you it's the plural
the morpheme dog and the morpheme plural
make the word dogs which has two
morphemes
a second concept to get you started is
in alle morph and alle morph is a
different way that the same morpheme can
show up we talked about morphemes as
being a general underlying concept I
gave you the example of dog with s and
that s is a plural Morphy you can see
that it makes the word plural if we add
that same plural s to another word we
sometimes see that it shows up
differently for example in the word hats
it shows up as an S sound and not as a
sound so the Z sound in the S sound are
two alle morphs of a single plural as
morphine there are different types of
morphemes there are morphemes that can
stand on their own like the word dog
these are known as free morphemes it
doesn't have to be attached to another
morpheme to be used morphemes that do
need to be attached to another morpheme
to be used are known as bound morphemes
take the example of plural s do you ever
say just s on its own demean plural
plural s always shows up at the end of
other morphemes like in dogs that makes
it a bound morpheme two types of bound
morphemes occur in English and a variety
of other languages derivational
morphemes and inflectional morphemes
derivational morphemes allow you to form
new words new concepts out of other
morphemes inflectional morphemes convey
grammatical information an example would
be the s in the word dogs that we've
already talked about a few times that
conveys the grammatical information hey
this words plural so keep an eye out for
both of these types pound morphemes are
generally bound in a fixed position with
respect to the morphemes they're
attaching to morphemes that attach
before another morpheme are known as
prefixes morphemes that occur after
another morpheme are known as suffixes
there are other examples that actually
occur inside of it either morphemes that
are called infixes and bound morphemes
that attach around another morpheme
which we call circum fixes I guess you
can say that these are a little more
exotic all of these are known as affixes
which is a Latin way of saying that
they're attached to another word
languages have other techniques at their
disposal for expressing grammatical
concepts one of these is a clinic which
is kind of like a free morphing kind of
like in ethics it sits alongside of and
is pronounced along with the word that
it grammatically relates to a zero
morpheme or a null morpheme is a
morpheme that doesn't get pronounced
this concept of a silent meaningful unit
is strange at first I know we can argue
for its existence based on the grammar
of a language so knowing that English
speakers differentiate between singular
and plural it could be argued that dog
actually carries a zero morpheme so
these two morphemes the free morpheme
dog and the bound morpheme zero morpheme
allow us to identify the categories
singular noun it's one dog and not
multiple dogs another fundamental
concept is periphery sis which uses
multiple words to express the same
grammatical concept that another
language might express using an
inflectional morphine there's also
compounding which takes two free
morphemes and sets them side-by-side to
represent a new concept in that way it's
kind of like attaching a derivational
morpheme in a language that allows it
but the two morphemes are free so we can
say for instance dog house dog house
which attaches the free morpheme dog and
the free morpheme house to come up with
a new concept rearranging word order is
also a useful technique that's very
common for expressing grammar we have
some additional terminology for talking
about languages that like to bind
morphemes
the root morpheme is the base that
carries most of the meaning any
derivational morphemes added to the root
would help form the stem to which a
fixes can be added inflectional affixes
would not be part of the stem any
derivational affixes however and the
root itself would be part of the stem
and if it's on its own it's both the
root and the stem languages that tend to
use bound morphemes are known as
synthetic languages because they tend to
put morphemes together to form words at
the other end of the spectrum an
analytic language does not
bound morphemes so each word on average
in an analytic language is a free
morpheme types of languages that use
bound morphemes include fusional
languages which are rarer but basically
fused together information grammatical
information into an inflectional affixes
so they tend to have a lot more meaning
in their affixes and fewer affixes
whereas agglutinative languages tend to
have more affixes but less overlap
between grammatical meanings in each
individual affix this lesson has covered
morphemes alle morphs and very roughly
how different individual languages build
outwards with morphemes be sure to check
out the page for more information and
exercises and I'll catch you in the next
lesson
you